Before we get started. Don't forget to check out our new channel visual Academy.
I think you might like it.
Conquering Egypt.
On this channel. We cover a lot of historical topics.
I'll leave you the link in the description,
but now let's get into today's video.
[Inaudible].
As we've told you, in previous videos on the 30th of June, 2020,
everything changed in Hong Kong on that day or Tuesday,
that will go down in history as a sad day for democracy,
the Chinese communist party and the model once. And for all,
they said goodbye to the policy of one country, two systems.
It did not do so as some expected through a shocking occupation of troops or
military force, but rather by way of agree,
vote in the national people's Congress standing committee,
which is the parliament of China that vote ratified the entry into force of a
new security law. In the former British club,
We are talking about a new law that in practice has put an end to freedom of
speech demonstration and political association among other things.
These were previously held the rights that had made Hong Kong.
One of the freest territories on the planet for decades as a result from the
1st of July, any social media platform,
traditional media agency publishing company or educational center has been in
the spotlight of the Chinese dictatorship. To give you an idea.
We have this law,
which will be applied by courts and special security forces and controlled
directly by Beijing.
Any action that the Chinese regime considers to promote sedition, subversion,
separatism,
or collusion with foreign forces could end in harsh prison terms and even life
imprisonment.
Friends.
The security law is a blank check for the Chinese government to pursue any
person or movement in Hong Kong that is inconvenient for them.
And as you can imagine, China,
hasn't held back and using this law repression and fear are two factors that
have now become part of everyday life in the South China sea enclave.
The new policy of both Beijing and the local authorities is to crack down firmly
on any show of this scent. Wait a minute. You don't believe me.
Do you really think I'm exaggerating well,
pay attention to the kind of headlines that have become commonplace in Hong Kong
these days? Huh?
Joshua Wong and Agnes ciao jailed for protest roles, democracy,
activists,
face months behind bars with more charges pending Asia Nikkei review
seven pro democratic lawmakers arrested in Hong Kong.
Asia Nikkei review used to see books critical of the authorities in Hong Kong.
Such books are now no longer seen in the bookstores.
You already Suzuki senior partner at law firm at Sumi and Sockeye.
The last time I saw many of my social media friends online was June 30th.
The day Beijing passed a national security law for Hong Kong.
My friend list is shortened and some reappeared with names that I did not
recognize many removed their accounts out of fear that they may be for even the
smallest slight against the government. Nicole Lou Ft.
Porter friends, since the start of the mass protests in 2019,
almost 10,000 people have been arrested and thousands prosecuted. However,
since the new national security law went into effect, things have gotten much.
Yes.
Give you an idea. Since the new law came into effect,
dozens of key pro democracy figures have been arrested,
including several legislators in August.
The police raided the offices of Apple daily.
One of the few media outlets not controlled by Beijing, Jimmy Lee,
the newspapers founder, along with eight others,
including two of his sons were arrested under the new security law.
And on the 2nd of December, or authorities denied Jimmy Lee,
even provisional freedom. On the 3rd of September 12,
pro-democracy activists were captured by the Chinese coast guard whilst
attempting a dramatic boat escape to Taiwan. The youngest was only 16 years old
And friends.
These are just three examples of what the new normality is for Hong Kong is,
but wait a moment, because this is not the end of it.
12th of November,
the Chinese authorities gave a new turn of the screw to this whole affair.
They authorized the Hong Kong government to permanently expel any legislator,
IE,
any member of parliament who is not considered sufficiently patriotic and most
strikingly. This expulsion order does not have to go through the local courts.
In other words, now the executive authority of Hong Kong,
which is elected by the Chinese government and which is currently led by Ms.
Carrie Lam can expel from the Hong Kong parliament,
any MPS that are inconvenient to them all with complete impunity and without any
judicial backing. So just minutes after this new rule went into effect,
four members of the opposition were expelled from parliament. In other words,
there is no longer any room for the opposition in the Hong Kong parliaments.
The government can now remove any face it wants from the parliament.
There will be no future for this legislature, Kenneth and Leon,
one of the expelled MPS.
The top it all off in her last annual policy speech, Hong Kong's,
chief executive, Carrie Lam called the security law,
remarkably effective and pledged to promote patriotic education.
You can imagine what that means, but all this,
my friends is something that we have talked more or less about already.
And I am very sure, very sure that very few of you will find it strange,
but the real questions are what are consequences of this political interference?
What are the strengths of this increasingly less autonomous region and the most
important question of all? What does China expect to need from Hong Kong?
Listen up.
The wall street of Asia.
Friends,
the former British colony became an important enclave during the 20th century,
not only a commercial one, but above all a financial one.
It's the legal system inspired by the British model,
which gave a lot of legal security,
enormous freedom of movement for people to capital and goods,
low taxes and English as the working language would just some of the elements
that catapulted it to the top of the international financial rankings.
That's not all the spectacular takeoff of the Chinese economy over the past
decades. You will soon see why has made Hong Kong.
The world's most important international financial center just behind New York
and London in 2019,
the Hong Kong stock exchange was the one that raised the most money with new
market outlets. It was placed above both the NASDAQ and the New York stock.
Okay. Exchange.
In 2020, things are not much different.
The Hong Kong stock exchange and the NASDAQ compete hand in hand for the
symbolic first place.
And there's a good.
For all of this. As you will know,
Hong Kong has been a part of China since 1997. However, as you also know,
it's international status has been an independent country in practice.
For example,
the 1992 Hong Kong policy act of the United States made to this territory,
a separate customs area from mainland China for all the years,
since the act and guaranteed currency comfortability.
And this is not the only regulation that exists.
Many agreements have shaped Hong Kong. For example,
the sec wall street security supervisor has an enforcement agreement with its
Hong Kong counterpart.
Many regulations are similar and it's financial derivatives companies are
treated by us agencies virtually as if they were local companies. In fact,
most banking and financial supervisors around the world treat Hong Kong
institutions almost as if they were based in Frankfurt itself.
All this has created a unique and highly competitive ecosystem.
Perhaps.
The most important feature, however,
is that it is the most prominent dollar funding center in all of Asia since 1983
it's currency. The Hong Kong dollar has been pegged to the us dollar,
a bond backed by reserves of more than $400 billion.
Put another way if you want, or need dollars in Asia,
Hong Kong is your go-to place.
Well.
It has all the characteristics that we have mentioned that explained why this
small enclave is such a bustling place.
Especially if we're talking about money with just over 7.5 million inhabitants,
163 different banks. Most of them international are established in Hong Kong.
Of course,
practically all the large entities in the world have operations in this place.
13% of all employment and 26% of its economy comes from the financial industry.
Now having said that there are some essential questions that we have to answer.
What role does Hong Kong play for China?
How important is the city for the economy of the Asian giant and take notes?
Because these two questions may have much more important implications than you
can imagine. Listen up.
How much does trynna need Hong Kong.
Friends?
It appears that the importance that Hong Kong has in the Chinese economy has
been reduced a lot over the last three decades. After all, if in 1993,
Hong Kong represented 27% of all China's GDP today,
that figure is less than 3%. In fact, in 2019,
the GDP of Shenzhen province exceeded that of Hong Kong.
Hold on a moment because the implements,
the significance of this special administrative region manifests itself in a
very different way while Hong Kong is becoming more and more Chinese,
its institutions have so far been left virtually equivalent to those of a
Western economy. I'm referring to examples of the courts, the regulators,
and the monetary authority.
All of these institutions have been functioning independently and effectively
for decades. And it's not just about public institutions.
This city is also full as a city like London is of all kinds of professionals
linked to the financial world who are highly specialized from law firms to asset
managers, analysts, and FinTech technologies. Thanks precisely to this.
Hong Kong has become something like a bridge between two very different worlds
on the one hand, the Western world and on the other,
the prosperous world of the new.
China.
All the Western financial system is categorized by free capital flows,
free dissemination of information and legal security.
Things are quite different. Still in China.
The control was on capital movements are still enormous while, well,
let's say that China is not famous for its legacy.
Currency.
Like any other dictatorship.
Really the fact is that precisely because of these differences,
Hong Kong plays a double role. On the one hand,
it is the main gateway to mainland China for foreign investment.
Not the other hand. It is the place where Chinese companies,
including the big public companies raise funds, particularly of course,
in us dollars. Remember that to conduct international operations,
having the dollar bills of the American empire is almost indispensable well in
the same way, if you were looking for you and to invest in China,
and you want to be able to change them with some freedom and have guarantees and
liquid security, Hong Kong,
exactly the door that you have to knock on because friends,
this city is not only the most important dollar financing center in Asia.
It is also the largest market for you ban outside, mainland China in the world.
Sauce.
Hong Kong is financial district is the place where entrepreneurs and technology
leaders in China make agreements with us hedge funds to raise financing.
While at the same time,
the large public banks in China issued bonds to finance new projects,
such as the new silk road.
It is also the place where dozens and dozens of Chinese companies are listed
including 421 companies controlled by the Chinese government itself.
At the end of the day,
being listed in Hong Kong means opening the door to investors and capital from
all over the world.
To give you an idea of the almost $75 billion that Chinese companies raised on
stock exchanges during 2019 about half came from the city.
And this also explains why more than 70% of the total capitalization in the Hong
Kong stock exchange corresponds to Chinese.
Companies.
Well,
the Chinese use this market to collect many savings and Chinese companies use it
to attract money investments and partners,
as well as to finance their projects abroad.
International investors also use it as a gateway to the Chinese giant,
according to data from Morgan Stanley in 2018, for example,
more than 60% of foreign direct investment in the Asian giant was channeled from
here from this city, from central, from the financial district of Hong Kong,
more than 60%.
So you see in a way Hong Kong is still indispensable to China.
Let's just say that eroding financial strength could lead to many problems for
Beijing on a moment that could happen with everything we told you at the
beginning of the video, couldn't it.
From global city to Chinese Ford.
Friends could have Hong Kong financial analyst question,
a large public company under the new rules. Could investors trust the courts?
If they are confronted with someone close to the Chinese communist party,
could economic information or analysis critical of the government to be
prosecuted,
could China make it harder to get free access to the web in Hong Kong?
If it did get prosecuted,
will senior professionals feel comfortable about accepting less freedom of
speech? What will happen to savings in the face of reduced legal security,
be careful friends. These are not minor questions.
This is the new scenario Hong Kong is facing. And particularly so,
and its famous financial center.
For example,
according to some surveys published after the security law was announced many
companies, most of them believe that this new law would affect them negatively.
A survey conducted in early August by the American chamber of commerce in Hong
Kong found that 75% of respondents were pessimistic about the business prospects
in the city and nearly 40% plans to move their capital operations or assets.
Yep.
And what happened with ant financial, for example, on 5th of November, 2020,
this company, which is something like the financial subsidiary of Alibaba,
we've due to start trading on the Hong Kong stock exchange.
It was the biggest IPO in the history of the planet. However,
a few days prior in late October its founder,
Jack ma was critical of the Chinese government at a financial forum in Shanghai.
Well, do you know what happened overnight?
The Chinese government suspended the IPO of this giant value to hundreds of
billions of us dollars. According to speculation,
it was using pink himself who made the decision.
And of course that doesn't seem like the best way to win the trust of investors
or to show that things in the new Hong Kong are going to run smoothly. Now,
does it
Friends, the future of Hong Kong,
particularly it's positioned as an international financial center is far from
clear. Everything indicates that it will gradually become more Chinese and less
international.
I don't know what the future of Hong Kong is going to be,
but I'm pretty sure it won't be a global financial center.
Hong Kong is now the financial center of China, which is somewhat different.
Alicia Garcia, Ferrero, chief economists for the Asia Pacific at [inaudible].
But of course, even if this were the case, it would still be bad for China.
It would weaken its financial connection with the rest of the world.
It could reduce the number of investment secured limit access to dollars and
increase the cost of capital for its companies.
That is the great risk that the Chinese government now faces,
although they publicly express a somewhat different idea.
What China Hong Kong and the international community most from Hong Kong is
stability at a return to order if law and order can be maintained.
There will be great interest around the world and continuing to invest in this
region as investors seek rapid growth and quick returns,
long way out advisor to the Chinese central government and president of the
center for China and globalization.
See in Beijing, they believe that by keeping things calm,
Hong Kong will not suffer, or at least it won't suffer much,
which may or may not be true in any case. That's the way things are.
And the question that comes up is, is there a plan B? Yes,
there is that that has a lot to do with Macau,
but that's a topic for a future video here on visual politics.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also.
This channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media. We have a
podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.